le nid d'oiseau ou le water cube devenu
ice cube des structures que pékin avait
construit pour les jo de 2008
réutiliser en 2022 cette notion de
recyclage est assez récente dans
l'histoire de l'organisation des jeux
prenons l'exemple des jo d'hiver de
grenoble en 1968 c'est toute une ville
qui a été modifié des axes routiers un
hôtel de ville une gare un hôpital un
aéroport c'était la volonté de l'étape
de booster la ville et sa région
mais quinze ans après le bilan était
mitigé monsieur le maire si vous deviez
recommencer l'expérience des jeux
olympiques en 1982 est ce que vous le
feriez vêtements honnêtement je ne
recommencerai pas est-ce que grenoble
sont encore le fardeau des jeux
olympiques quinze ans après il reste
bien entendu à payer encore des emprunts
mais honnêtement nous aurions dû au fil
des ans
faire ce qui était fait en deux ans et
demi et donc le fardeau souhaite encore
plus lourd je crois pouvoir honnêtement
dire que les jeux olympiques nous ont
aidés nous en donne un coup de pouce
même sur le plan financier les
grenoblois ont tout de même dû
rembourser les dettes des jo jusqu'en
1995 et au delà des dettes il y a aussi
ce qu'on appelle les éléphants blancs
des structures déserté un emblème en
france le tremplin construit à saint
dizier pour les jo de grenoble justement
quelques points noirs tout de même le
tremplin de saint nizier n'est utilisé
qu'une seule fois par an et encore
admirablement situé il donne aux
sauteurs l'impression de survoler
grenoble mais cela fait deux ans que
l'on ne veulent plus un saint nizier
autre raté les jo d'athènes en 2004 ou
de rio en 2016 les enceintes sportives
devait être transformé en école par
exemple mais rien à la place des stades
qui rouille
autre raté écologique celui ci les jeux
de sotchi en russie en 2014
pourtant les jeux les plus chers de
l'histoire 36 milliards d'euros ici il
ya cinq ans il y avait une réserve
naturelle des marais des oiseaux
migrateurs et une plage connus des seuls
initiés
aujourd'hui bétonner la plage a perdu
tout son cachet quant à la mère elle est
impropre à la baignade selon les normes
internationales dette éléphants blancs
catastrophe écologique mais certaines
villes comme barcelone en 1992 ou
londres en 2012 ont réussi le pari de
faire des jo un accélérateur de projets
en repensant tout un quartier comme ici
à londres dix sept mille sportifs loge
et ici il ya cinq ans aujourd'hui les
familles ont remplacé les athlètes 95%
des 2800 appartements proposés à la
location ont trouvé preneur une vie de
quartier s'est développée c'est un
miracle pour tous ceux qui ont connu
l'endroit dix ans auparavant aujourd'hui
le cio se dit vigilant quant aux
dépenses engagées à voir après les jeux
de pékin le montant de la note
[Musique]